david wait
nope is there no way we can get rid of
him
not without cause michael i have cause
it is because i hate him so uh have you
felt the vibe yet
we work hard we play hard sometimes we
play hard and we should be working hard
right
um i guess the uh
the atmosphere that i've created here is
that i'm a friend first and a boss
second probably uh
an entertainer third just a second
right
oh hey do you uh
do you like the jamie kennedy experiment
yeah and punk'd and all that kind of
stuff okay um you were gonna be my
accomplice just go along with it okay
all right just follow my lead don't pimp
me all right come in so uh corporate
just said that i don't want to oh thank
you pam pam can you come in here for a
sec
just have a seat i was gonna call you in
anyway um
you know ryan
um as you know there is going to be
downsizing and uh you have made my life
so much easier
in that i am going to have to let you go
first
what why
why well theft
and stealing
stealing
um
what am i supposed to have stolen
post-it notes
post-it notes yeah okay what are those
worth like 50 cents 50 cents yeah you
steal a thousand post-it notes at 50
cents a piece and you know you've made a
profit
margin you know go
run us out of business pam
are you serious
yeah i am um
i can't believe this i mean i've never
even stolen as much as a paper clip and
now you're firing me
but the best thing about it is that uh
we're not gonna have to give you any
severance pay
because that is
gross misconduct and uh
i just clean out your desk i'm sorry
you've been ex-punk
[Laughter]
surprise it's a joke we were joking
around
let's see
okay he was in on it he was my
accomplice and
there was just kind of a morale booster
thing and we were showing the new guy
around kind of
kind of giving him the field of place
so
you
god you were we totally got you're a
jerk
i don't know about that
so
okay everybody shh what's up
earlier today stan lee sassed me and
toby gave me some suggestions on how to
discipline him they did not work
obviously because they were stupid so i
am now going to fake
fire him
what does that mean it's like a mock
execution that's not a good idea yes it
is a good idea it's the only possible
solution i have left well you can
actually fire him no okay
i've had enough of you why are you
telling us this because i want you to
behave as if i'm actually firing him
oscar okay michael if you hadn't told us
this
then we would have thought that you were
actually firing i'm not firing him i'm
not i need you to act like i am firing
him
just what i'm going to do is i'm going
to pretend that i'm firing him and i
need you to act like i am firing him do
you get that do you get it i'm teaching
him a lesson he needs to learn humility
all right that's all i'm okay here he
comes let's just
play act
stanley may i talk to you for a second
stanley hudson
you are fired
are you serious
i am serious we are all serious
you're fired like a heart attack you're
firing me
over three words
have you lost your mind
do you think i'm gonna let you do this
to me hmm i've watched you screw up this
office for 10 years and i'm filing a
lawsuit and i'm gonna tell them about
every stupid thing you've ever done up
in this office all right okay you know
what
now you know how i feel
this was a fake firing
lesson learned good work everybody very
nice
so i'm not fired
that's it
and uh
do you have anything to say to me oh yes
i do
you are out of your damn little
pea-sized mind what is wrong with you do
you have any sense at all okay do you
have any idea how to run an office yes
every day you do something stupider than
you did the day before and i think
there's no possible way he can top that
but what do you do you find a way damn
it to top it you are a professional
idiot hey stop it
damn
you come in here please
have a seat
okay
well there's no easy way of saying this
so i think i will just
drag it out
since the dawn of time just tell me
i gave ryan the sales job
there just weren't enough clients for
the two of you
so i had to
oh sorry i'm sorry i get it
why are you giggling
is this a joke michael is this
did i get the job
yes i did yeah for real you're not
kidding me
i didn't you're the best person for the
job you're gonna be great
okay thank you
thank you oh thank you oh you will not
be sorry is it your face oh man
oh that was classic
i really thought i didn't get it oh
really
yeah
because you said i did good
that was really good what about ryan
i don't know i offered him his temp job
back we'll see
he was not happy at all when i offered
him this job and then i told him that he
didn't get the job though yeah maybe you
shouldn't fake fire people anymore i
don't appreciate you telling me what to
do so clean out your desk you are
through here
thanks michael oh
what's our receptionist name erin could
you send her in
erin michael wants to see you
hello
have a seat
you